finally the most recognizable voice in
America sings I can feel it coming in
the air tonight
Aldo Ray Romano sings the greatest hits
of all time
on two compact discs car Mulaney come
come my lady you're my butterfly sugar
red bag
you're a pretty room mono sing of the
time step to the border cuz I am a
champion
and the hits just keep coming oh I don't
know
give me the money hey hey do you like
girlfriend oh yeah oh yeah think you
need a new one Hey Hey You you I could
be your girlfriend yeah
only 1995 plus shipping and handling and
if you order now we'll throw in free of
charge Romano
brats here we go yo here we go yo so
what so what so what Dustin there we go
y'all know about invite one of America's
top comedians back into your home this
time on your stereo Romano sings